from total lockdown to wearing masks and
social distancing
it's safe to say that covid19 has become
part
of everyday life the new normal could be
here for quite some time to come
but how did we get into this position
the editor of one of the world's leading
medical journals has written a book
outlining how the virus has evolved and
how the world has responded
to it is with us now it's richard horton
he's the editor-in-chief
of the lancet hello to you
good morning k good morning what is it
about covid19 that has made it such
an insidious virus
well first of all it's insidious because
it's brand new
it's difficult to imagine but at the
beginning of this year we didn't even
know this virus
existed it's part of a group of
viruses the coronaviruses and we know
that two
in particular have had very severe
effects
on human beings in the past sars from
early 2000s and
a virus called mers middle eastern
respiratory syndrome
and the disease that this particular
virus that we're experiencing their
causes
is is really severe uh in those
early stages in the pandemic people
doctors were completely shocked about
the severity
of the disease the multi-organ failure
it caused and the high rates of
mortality
of those who are admitted to intensive
care
did politicians act in the right way in
the early days
no um they did not uh you know
the whole story of the past eight months
was laid out in a series of papers that
we published at the end of january
and that story of the severity of the
disease the fact that there's no
treatment
no vaccine the need for ppe the need for
wide scale
testing all of the issues that we've
been debating
was laid out then and yet it wasn't
until
march that the government took this
seriously
we wasted six to eight weeks when we
could
have been preparing for what hit us in
march
through to the present and that was an
astonishing political failure
they did say that they were following
the science throughout
and i'm afraid to say that some of the
responsibility
is shared between not just the
politicians but also
the scientists and i think that as we
look back over the events of the last
eight months we need to ask ourselves
why was it that the multiplicity
of government committees and medical
officers
and scientific advisors that we have
across all four
countries of the united kingdom didn't
pick up the signals
from china in those early days back in
january
because the whole story was laid out
then so there was not just a political
failure
there was also a failure of the
scientific policy advice being given to
government
i wonder why it is that more developed
countries than i'd like to think that
the united kingdom
and europe is part of that is dealing
with covert 19
in the same way as less developed
countries i.e
um quarantine lockdown masks it doesn't
seem to be you know it seems to be
pretty basic the way that we're dealing
with it at the moment
very very basic messages that actually
if if you go back over the last three
four hundred years
this has been the way uh infectious
outbreaks have been dealt with from the
since the time of the bubonic plague
there isn't much that's
different if you go back for example to
the 17th century
when there were three or four outbreaks
of bubonic plague
how did people cope in london and tens
of thousands of people died from the
plague
in the 17th century well what happened
was the city was locked down
and those who could afford it exited the
city to go and live in the suburbs or in
the countryside
they practiced a form of physical
distancing so the messages are exactly
the same they haven't changed
and they're globally relevant and
actually i think that's where the most
important government failure today
is and that is a failure of
communication if you walk around cities
today
i'm sure you see people are assembling
they're mixing
they're not wearing masks they are not
physically distancing
and we are the country right now is on a
precipice
with children back at school students
going back to universities people being
encouraged to go
to work and with winter coming we are in
real danger if we don't get the
messaging right
that we will have a resurgence but do
you accept that the government is also
dancing on the head of a pin and it has
to deal with the mental health of the
country as well and
a lot of people have struggled with
lockdown
i fully agree with that and that's why
lockdown is not the answer what we have
to do
is we have to renegotiate our
relationship with the virus and what i
mean by that
is that we have to accept and understand
that this virus is with us
it's going to be with us for a long time
to come a vaccine is not going to be a
magic bullet that suddenly takes
all the risks and dangers away and
therefore
we are going to have to change our
behaviors in order to live with the
virus around us but at the moment those
messages
about the scale of the of the
transformation in our society that's
taken place i don't think of being
communicated
anywhere near forcibly enough and that's
why people are relaxing why they are
mixing
and why they aren't practicing these
basic messages and why we are seeing
3 000 cases as we saw over the weekend
it's coming back if we're not
careful we are seeing 3 000 cases but
we're not seeing the same number of
deaths correlating
to those numbers and that's what
particularly young people is saying okay
i might get it
but it's not going to kill me
no that's absolutely right but young
people don't live in their own bubble
young people are mixing with older
people and if you
look at the hospital mortality for
example
the mortality is very tightly linked to
aa
and if a young person passes
is mixing with somebody who is for
example
over 50 or 60 or 70 years old as we will
be in our families
then that's where the danger comes you
can't isolate
young people a sort of under 40 age
group
who are not mixing with others in our
society
so young people could become the source
for spreading the virus to older groups
and those are the people who are then
particularly at risk how likely
do you think there will be a second wave
unless communication gets strengthened
um i think it's very likely that we will
see a resurgence
you know i those of a certain age and
i'm afraid i'm of a certain age i
remember the messaging
that a conservative government actually
led on in the early stages of the aids
epidemic
and that was a brilliant response to a
grave threat
really clear messaging regularly
delivered very simple very hard hitting
and persistent in terms of the frequency
of that messaging
and that's what we need now we're not
seeing that across
all media with all methods to get
those simple ideas through to the public
and that's why you're seeing this
relaxation we don't need a lockdown
but we mustn't relax our vigilance and
it's vigilance that
that is the most important priority now